-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
Let's get to the news.
Secretary of State Tony Blinken
testified today before the
Senate Foreign Affairs Committee
about the U.S. withdrawal
from Afghanistan,
but not before trying
every other topic first.
"Okay, before we get to that,
who wants to hear what is
in Area 51?"
[ Laughter ]
After former President
George W. Bush appeared
to compare Capitol rioters
to foreign terrorists,
in a speech commemorating
the September 11th attacks,
former President Trump
said yesterday that Bush
"shouldn't be
lecturing anybody."
And I never thought
I'd say this sentence, but,
Bush, Trump,
you're both right.
[ Laughter ]
The U.S. will host
a virtual summit
with global leaders next week,
called
"Global COVID-19 Summit:
Ending the Pandemic
and Building Back Better."
In related news,
the Mets are hosting a seminar
at the Hyatt Regency, called
"How to Win the World Series."
[ Laughter ]
Russian President Vladimir Putin
is reportedly self-isolating
after several members
of his entourage
tested positive
for the coronavirus.
And they must have
some new variant over there
because one of the symptoms is
falling off a balcony.
[ Laughter ]
A group of Senate Democrats
introduced
new voting rights
legislation today
which would make Election Day
a public holiday
and require same-day
voter registration,
while Senate Republicans
introduced legislations
that you have to have
six forms of ID,
be able to beat the underwater
levels in "Mario,"
and reunuite Oasis.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Senate Democrats
introduced a new
voting rights bill
which would make Election Day
a public holiday.
But not for you, Kornacki!
24 straight hours on your feet.
No bathroom breaks for Kornacki!
[ Laughter ]
House Democrats yesterday
proposed now tax increases
on corporations,
the wealthy, investors,
and high-income business owners.
And this is weird --
they announced it
on AOC's dress.
[ Laughter ]
After she announced
that she has not received
the coronavirus vaccine,
rapper Nicki Minaj
tweeted yesterday
that a friend of her cousin
received the shot
"& became impotent"
after "His testicles
became swollen."
Which is pretty shocking
because,
when I got the shot,
it was in my arm.
[ Laughter ]
A new study suggests that cows
can be potty-trained
as easily as toddlers.
"Then I know
what the problem is,"
said your plumber.
[ Laughter ]
"It's, uh,
it's cow [bleep]."
[ Laughter ]